[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon.
My name is Immaculata De Vivo.
And I am the interim co-director
for science programming
for academic adventures
at Radcliffe Institute.
So Radcliffe
Institute is comprised
of three large programs.
There is the
Schlesinger Library.
There's the very prestigious
Radcliffe Fellows.
Thank you to any of the
Fellows who are here today.
And then, of course,
Academic Ventures,
which Rebecca Wassarman is the
executive director and Sean
O'Donnell also is part
of the Academic Ventures.
And under Academic
Ventures, they
are the ones who are
actually sponsoring
"This Next in Science."
It is a very
innovative programming
that brings in lots of
diversity with respect
to humanities, science, art.
And predicated on that are
all of the programming.
So Academic
Ventures, in addition
to the "Next in
Science" series, also
sponsors these
exploratory seminars
and accelerated workshops.
These are funding opportunities
to bring in, again,
a very multidisciplinary team
to ask the big questions,
to have--
to brainstorm, essentially.
And they are submitted by
Harvard faculty or a Radcliffe
Fellow or a prior
Radcliffe Fellow.
But you can go to the website
to get more information.
In addition to these
symposiums and workshops,
Academic Ventures sponsors
these very large symposiums,
the very successful
"Undiscovered" on October 26.
And there was such
great buzz about that
we're continuing to run series
from that "Undiscovered."
They also sponsor exhibits,
like the "Measure" exhibit
on Thursday and, of course,
the "Next in Science" series,
which is what I'm going to
briefly tell you about today.
But more importantly, the
richness of Academic Ventures
is to open up these
incredible symposiums
and lectures and
events to the public
so we can all be
enriched by the events.
So the "Next in
Science" is really
an opportunity for early career
scientists, the rising rock
stars.
And we bring them together.
They have overlapping
research interests.
And they not only meet each
other, but they meet all of you
and exchange ideas
to the Harvard-wide,
campus-wide, Boston-wide.
And today's "Next
in Science" idea
came from this
understanding of evolution.
Most people think we're
done with evolution.
But really, we're not.
So we have the past,
the current, and what
is the future of evolution.
And the four bright
stars today will address
some of those questions.
So the focus is on evolution.
And I don't want to
take too much time.
But just the overview
is that we will
start with Neanderthal
human integration.
And then we'll move on to
human migration and the impact
of environment and
just change, how
natural selection
works with respect
to disease and other traits.
And then we'll have a break.
And we'll have two other-- the
two speakers in the afternoon--
later afternoon will speak
about rapid evolution in fish.
And then our last speaker will
speak about urban evolution
as measured with white
clover, a plant, which
everyone has in their garden.
I can guarantee you,
whether you want it or not.
So with that, I would like
to introduce our very first
speaker, Sriram Sankararaman.
He is an assistant
professor in the Department
of Computer Science at the
human genetics at UCLA.
And his interest is the
interface of computer science,
statistics, and biology.
He's pretty much the genomicist
that we are very familiar with.
They give us lots of data on
a lot of different aspects
of biology.
But I was intrigued by
Sriram when his paper
on the Neanderthal
integration with humans--
and that's what he's going
to talk about today--
"Archaic Admixture
in Human History."
So Sriram?
[APPLAUSE]
- All right, firstly, I'd like
to say, I'm really excited.
This is a great meeting.
And I'm looking forward
to interacting with you
and learning about
everybody's work.
What I'm going to
talk about today
is basically to give you
an idea of this revolution
and our understanding
of human evolution
that's been enabled by the fact
that we can now get DNA out
of ancient individuals.
So specifically, I'm going
to talk about the fact
that we have genome sequences
from archaic populations.
By that, we mean populations
like the Neanderthals, which
are closely related
to modern humans,
but not quite modern human.
And given the genomes of
these archaic populations,
we'd like to understand
the relationships
between archaic
and modern humans.
So specifically,
we're going to talk
about intermixing or admixture
between archaic and modern
humans.
And what I'd like to give you a
feel for is, how do we actually
learn about this
given genomic data?
And given that we've
learned about it,
what are kind of
the consequences
of this archaic admixture
for human evolution
and human biology?
So by looking at genomes
from present-day humans,
we have acquired a broad
outline of human evolution
or human history over the
last couple of 100,000 years.
So we know that modern
humans evolved in Africa.
And about 100,000
years ago, there
was a migration or
exit out of Africa.
All populations
outside of Africa
trace their ancestry
to this small subset
that exited Africa.
Now there's a
wrinkle to the story.
And that comes from the fact
that as this population left
Africa, there was another
population in much of Europe
and Central Asia,
the Neanderthals.
And so the Neanderthals were
in this geographic range
from about 300,000 years
till about 30,000 years
when they disappear
from the fossil record.
So there's a lot of debate--
there was a lot of
debate, there continues
to be a lot of debate about the
interaction between these two
populations.
Did these two populations meet?
Was there interbreeding?
So one major step in trying to
understand this relationship
came with the sequencing of
the first Neanderthal genome.
So this was the cave
in Croatia from which
the bones that yielded the
first draft Neanderthal genome
were obtained.
And given this first
draft Neanderthal genome,
it made sense to look at this
question of interbreeding.
And so the question or the
statistical test that was asked
was, if you take a
Neanderthal genome
and compare it to the genomes
of two modern human individuals,
for example, if you look
at an African genome
and a non-African genome, is
the Neanderthal genome closer
to one relative to the other?
And what was observed
in this initial study
was non-Africans as
a whole tend to be
genetically closer
to Neanderthals
relative to Africans.
So this observation is
consistent with a history
where there was interbreeding
between Neanderthals
and non-Africans
after non-Africans
split from Africans.
In other words, there was this
population that left Africa.
And before the dispersal into
the different non-African
populations, they met and
interbred with Neanderthals.
So given that this was
a plausible history,
a question is, can we
come up with estimates
of when this admixture
might have happened?
So to do this, we use the
fact that when genomes
are transmitted from
parents to offspring,
there's a process
called recombination,
which shuffles up the genome
that gets transmitted.
So, for example,
in this cartoon,
you have a modern
human and an archaic.
And the offspring, for
example, this individual,
inherits one genome from the
archaic parent and the other
from the modern human parent.
But in the next
generation, the offspring
is going to have a mosaic.
And that's because
of this recombination
that ends up shuffling the
genome that gets transmitted.
And this happens
after every generation
so that when you look
at an individual,
say, 50,000 years later,
this individual's genome
is going to have
this mosaic pattern
with the modern human
chunks interspersed
with the archaic chunks.
And roughly the length
of these segments
is indicative of the
time of admixture.
So the greater the
time since admixture,
the shorter the chunks.
So by looking at the length of
the chunks of Neanderthal DNA
that are present in
non-African genomes,
we were able to say
that interbreeding
between Neanderthals
and modern humans
is roughly about 50,000
years before present.
So this is consistent
with what we
know about the "Out of Africa"
event, so the "Out of Africa"
event being dated to
about 100,000 years.
So this is consistent
with integration
into the non-Africans
after they left Africa.
We can also use other kinds
of statistical techniques
to estimate what fraction of the
non-Africans' ancestry traces
to Neanderthals.
And our current
estimate is about 2%
of the ancestry of
non-African populations traces
back to Neanderthals.
So with this, we
have what I would
think of as a global
picture of the relationship
between modern humans
and Neanderthals.
We think that humans
and Neanderthals
split about of the order of
300,000 years in the past.
And then Africans
and non-Africans
split about 100,000
years ago, followed
by interbreeding between
Neanderthals into the ancestors
of non-Africans.
So this gives us
a global picture.
And the implication is if you
look at non-African genomes
today, they're
going to be carrying
these chunks of Neanderthal DNA,
these chunks that are actually
quite distinct and diverged
from the rest of the DNA that's
floating around.
So this begs the
question, what was
the effect of this highly
distinctive DNA that's
embedded within the
modern human gene pool?
Does it have a functional
impact or is it
just random bits of
DNA floating around?
So here's one example of
a concrete impact of some
of this Neanderthal DNA.
So this was a study that
happened four years back, which
was a scan for genes that are
associated with type 2 diabetes
risk.
And this scan turned
up a particular gene.
And it turns out that the risk
variant in this particular gene
has a very specific
and interesting
geographic distribution.
The risk variant is found
mostly in the Americas
at high frequencies.
It's quite rare
outside of America,
maybe at lower frequencies in
Europe, but essentially absent
in Africa.
So this is exactly the
kind of distribution
you would expect if this
risk gradient was introduced
into the modern human gene
pool through interbreeding
with Neanderthals.
And it turns out, if you do
some additional analysis,
this risk variant can be
shown to actually have
Neanderthal origins.
So this was one
specific example,
one gene that we traced back
to Neanderthal interbreeding.
The question is, what can we say
about the rest of the genome?
Can we systematically go and
label individuals' genomes
and try to identify the
origins of Neanderthal DNA
within individual genomes?
So what we need to do is we
need to build what we call
a map of Neanderthal ancestry.
What we mean by
that is if you look
at present-day
non-African individual,
their genome has
this mosaic pattern.
There are these red chunks of
Neanderthal DNA floating around
in the rest of their genome.
And we'd like to
be able to identify
what these red chunks are.
And so we built a
statistical method
that actually goes and
fishes for these chunks
in a modern human genome.
The basic idea is that it looks
at the modern human genome
and compares it to a
Neanderthal as well
as to an African genome.
The African genomes don't
have Neanderthal DNA.
So by doing this
comparison, we can
try to identify places
which are likely to be
of Neanderthal origin.
And what we get from this
kind of a statistical models
looks like this.
So what we are looking at here
are places along the genome.
And you're looking
at places where
the model says it's highly
confident that there
is Neanderthal DNA.
So that's what
these spikes denote.
And what you're
seeing here is when
we look at genomes of a European
American or an East Asian,
there are a number of regions
along the genome where
the model is highly
confident of Neanderthal DNA.
However, when we apply
it to an African genome,
there are relatively
few such regions.
So this is telling us that
the model is doing something
reasonable, that it's actually
consistent with our knowledge
of history.
So using this technique, we can
build what we term population
maps of Neanderthal ancestry.
In other words, we can go
to a given population, say
European genomes, and for
every region we can ask,
what percentage of individuals
carry Neanderthal DNA
at this region?
And so you're sliding along the
genome of these individuals.
And you're building these
maps which tell you,
in this position, many
European individuals carrying
Neanderthal DNA, whereas in
this region, relatively few do.
And so what I'm showing
here is this map
of Neanderthal ancestry
for European populations
and East Asian populations.
So what is interesting
about this map
is this rapid variation
in Neanderthal DNA
as you move along the genome.
There are places where there
is a lot of Neanderthal DNA
concentrated, what we term as
peaks of Neanderthal ancestry.
And then there are places
where, essentially, there
is no Neanderthal DNA across
these populations, what
we term as deserts.
So it's interesting
to understand
what might be causing
this variation
in Neanderthal ancestry.
Is this just a random
occurrence or is there
some biology, is there
some selective advantage
for some regions to be peaks
and others to be deserts?
So here is one extreme example
of a peak of Neanderthal DNA.
This is a place in the
genome where more than half
of Europeans carry the
Neanderthal version
of the gene.
So to give you a sense of
this, today more than half
of Europeans carry the
Neanderthal version
of the gene.
50,000 years ago,
it was about 2%.
But this is a place
where the frequency
of the Neanderthal DNA has risen
over the last 50,000 years.
And so there are several such
regions in the genome which
are peaks of Neanderthal DNA
and which we can strongly say
are places where the Neanderthal
DNA has risen up in frequency
not by chance, but
because it must
have had an adaptive impact.
It was beneficial once it
entered the modern human gene
pool.
And that's why it
rose up in frequency.
We can then ask what
might be the functional
impact of these peaks
of Neanderthal DNA,
were there specific
kinds of functions
that they were associated with?
And in fact, there
are several kinds
of functions that we
associate with these peaks.
For example, we find
that many of these peaks
of Neanderthal DNA are
associated with skin
and hair-related function.
So the suggestion here
is that the reason why
this Neanderthal DNA
rose up in frequency
was because they affected
skin and hair biology.
And that might have been
adaptively beneficial
because Neanderthals were
already in the environments
into which modern humans
were then expanding.
So borrowing this
DNA from Neanderthals
was a quick way
for modern humans
to adapt to these new
kinds of environments.
So now we can turn our
attention to the deserts
of Neanderthal DNA.
So these are large places in
the genome several million bases
long where, essentially,
nobody seems
to be carrying Neanderthal DNA.
That's quite surprising.
And the question
is, is it because
of the fact that
these places are
resistant to Neanderthal DNA?
Is it driven because of
the fact that these places
are functionally
important for humans?
So these are places
which are preserving
some kind of human
function and that
is why the Neanderthal DNA is
being resisted and removed.
So here is one such a
striking example of a desert.
It's a desert in every
population we've looked at.
It's a desert in Europeans
and in East Asians.
And this desert overlaps a
famous gene called FOXP2.
And this region, this
gene is interesting
because it's been
shown to be involved
in speech and language.
So our hypothesis is
that, potentially, there
is some function conferred
around this region that
is important for modern humans.
And that is why
this is resistant
to the Neanderthal
version of the DNA.
So to look at this a little
bit more quantitatively,
we looked at different
places in the genome.
And we binned them
according to how constrained
they are by selection.
So there are places
in the genome which
are very constrained where
there is no toleration
for new kinds of mutations.
And those are on the left.
And then there are places which
are more relaxed on the right.
And what we see is both in
Europeans and East Asians,
as you move towards regions
where they are strongly
constrained, there's a
reduction in the amount
of Neanderthal ancestry
or the Neanderthal DNA.
So this is telling us,
overall, the genome
is purifying away most of
the Neanderthal ancestry.
So the Neanderthal
ancestry, on average,
tends to be deleterious.
So even though there are
peaks of Neanderthal DNA
which are beneficial,
the big picture
is the Neanderthal
DNA is deleterious.
So one question is,
what causes this?
And there are still
several models out there.
One model is, the
study is Neanderthals
had a very small population
size over a long period of time.
So they accumulated lots
of deleterious mutations,
bad mutations.
And these came into
the human population
through the admixture.
And they were quickly removed
from the human population.
That's one model to try to
explain this kind of impact
of Neanderthal ancestry.
There is a second model
and this comes out
of what we know about
how species form.
So, for example, when you
have two populations that
split and evolve and
become two species,
there's a question
of what is driving
this formation of species.
And so this is a model called
a hybrid sterility model.
The idea is these
populations accumulate
mutations, which do just fine
as long as they are isolated.
But the moment they come
back together and they mix,
these mutations tend to be bad.
So, for example,
the Neanderthals
accumulated some mutations.
They came into the
human gene pool.
And they have interactions
that causes them to be removed.
It turns out, this model makes
two kinds of predictions.
One is, if you look at the
X chromosome, one of the sex
chromosomes, and compare it
to the rest of the genome,
the effects of Neanderthal
DNA getting purged
will be much more stronger
on the X chromosome
compared to the
rest of the genome.
And that's, indeed, what we
see, where the X chromosome has
substantially reduced
Neanderthal DNA compared
to the autosomes in
Europeans and East Asians.
There's a second prediction
from this model, which
is the effects of this
kind of a model would
be substantial on
genes which are highly
expressed in the testes.
And what we find is when
you look at testes genes,
again, there is a substantial
depletion in Neanderthal DNA.
So it's plausible that there
are both kinds of models,
both the hybrid sterility model,
as well as this model where
there is reduced population
sizes in the Neanderthals
contributing to
their DNA being bad
and being removed from
the human gene pool.
So so far I've talked only about
the Neanderthal population.
But what's emerged in
the last several years
is this discovery of a second
arctic population which is
a cousin of the Neanderthals.
So this population is
called the Denisovans.
And this is a notable
population because its discovery
came mainly from
genetics so there
was no prior fossil evidence
suggesting the existence
of this population.
So after the Denisovan
genome was sequenced, again,
there was a question, has there
been intermixing or admixture
between Denisovans and
certain human populations?
And what was discovered was that
populations in Oceania today,
present-day Oceania--
so these are populations
like the Papuans, Aboriginal
Australians--
have admixture from the
Denisovan population.
So Oceanian populations have
both Neanderthal DNA as well as
Denisovan DNA.
Like we did for
the Neanderthals,
we can also try to figure out
the date of this interbreeding
event.
And by looking at the
lengths of the Denisovan DNA
that's segregating
in the Oceanians,
we estimate this to be
around 45,000 years ago.
So this was after the
Neanderthal interbreeding
event.
Again, we can build maps of
Denisovan DNA around the world.
So here, I'm showing
you the results
of looking at a
worldwide population.
And every dot here
is a population.
And the color is telling you
how much Denisovan DNA is there
in this population
across that genome.
So we see this red spot here.
Those are the Oceanians.
So they have substantially
higher Denisovan DNA.
But then you see
this smear of green
in a set of other populations.
So East Asian
populations, South Asian
populations also have a small,
but non-negligible proportion
of Denisovan DNA.
So what the spread is telling
us is this Denisovan population,
which we don't have as
much fossil evidence about,
we only know it
from the genetics,
could potentially have had
a wide geographic range.
And we also have
evidence that there
was multiple mixing
events involving
Denisovans and modern
human population groups.
We can also build maps
along the genome looking at,
where is this Denisovan
DNA distributed?
So we can build, like, maps of
Denisovan and Neanderthal DNA
and compare them.
And, again, we see a
very similar picture
of peaks and deserts of
Denisovan and Neanderthal DNA.
So there are regions
like this that
also include the
FOXP2 gene, which
are deserts of both Denisovan
and Neanderthal DNA.
And then there are
peaks of Denisovan DNA.
The most notable one, this
amazing story in Tibetans,
focuses on a gene called EPAS1.
And this is a gene where
there is a high proportion
of Denisovan DNA in Tibetans.
And that has been
useful in adaptation
to high altitude environments.
So it's a clear example
of this archaic DNA being
useful in human adaptation.
So finally, we can again
ask, is the Denisovan DNA,
like the Neanderthal DNA,
deleterious on average?
And, again, when we
look at the genome,
as we move towards highly
constrained regions
of the genome, like
the Neanderthal DNA,
the Denisovans are also purged
in this highly selectively
constrained regions
of the genome.
So what it's telling us is
archaic DNA, both Neanderthal
and Denisovan, on
the whole seems
to have had very
similar effects.
On average, it was bad.
But there were places where they
could have actually provided
an evolutionary advantage.
So just to summarize,
I think the key message
that I want to
say is ancient DNA
is this amazing new
technology that's
giving us a new way
to ask questions
about human evolution.
I've mainly focused on
archaic genomes, genomes
from Neanderthals
and Denisovans,
but there are now
hundreds, maybe thousands
of genomes from what we'd
call ancient modern humans,
people who lived in
the last 10,000 years.
And that's giving
us new insights
into very recent
human evolution.
So using these
archaic genomes, we're
able to build maps of
Neanderthal and Denisovan
ancestry across populations.
And the key picture
that's coming out of this
is the complexity of the
interactions of Neanderthals,
Denisovans, and modern humans.
It's not just one
interbreeding event.
There are multiple
interbreeding events separated
across space and time.
The other interesting
idea is you
can think of using
this integration
or interbreeding as a tool
to understand human evolution
and human biology.
And I think that's
going to be powerful
and something that's what
thinking more deeply about.
With this, I'd like
to thank everyone.
I'd like to thank the members of
the Neanderthal Genome Analysis
Consortium.
This is where all
of this work began.
And I'd like to thank
all my funding sources.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Sriram.
That was great.
So we only have about five
minutes of questions right now.
OK, yes, can you please
state your name and question?
- Yes, can you give me
a number about how long
a segment of
Neanderthal DNA would
be inside me or in a
random Homo sapien.
So are we talking 50
bases or 50,000 bases?
And how many of them are there?
- Right, so the question
is, how many, how long
are these segments
of Neanderthal DNA?
So based on these time
estimates of around 50,000 years
on average, these segments are
of the order of 50,000 bases.
So that's kind of
the average length.
Although, there is
a lot of variation.
There can be extremely long
and extremely short segments.
In terms of numbers, I
don't have a specific number
to quote because it
depends on which individual
genome you're looking at.
Different individuals will
be carrying different subsets
of Neanderthal DNA.
- Thank you.
- I'm Heather [? Ramoff. ?]
Bit of a fanciful--
- Can you please
talk into the mic.
- Yeah, I'm Heather
[? Ramoff. ?]
And this is a bit of
a fanciful question.
But I'm thinking of the
traits [? most ?] where
their concentration of traits
relating to skin and hair
and those where there's
a desert with the FOXP2--
is that what it is--
relating to language.
And it seems to
me that those are
things that would
express themselves
both by looking at an individual
and behaviorally in terms
of the speech.
Do you consider at all
whether, in addition
to natural selection,
some sexual selection
is coming into play here?
- Absolutely, I
don't think we can
differentiate whether
this was sexual
versus natural selection.
I think the effects of either
of those modes of selection
are going to be quite similar.
So it is entirely possible.
And it's entirely
possible, for example,
that there were
different mating systems
across these populations.
And that plays into how
selection functions.
So it's very plausible.
I don't think we can
differentiate those two
scenarios here.
- Yeah, thank you.
- All right, I noted that your
distribution of genome types
did not include any
symbols in Africa.
So I thought there was
evidence that there was re--
certain people returning
from Europe to Africa.
But of course, over
the last 1,000 years,
this would have
been entirely mixed.
So I was wondering if there
was evidence from samples
of more than 1,000 years
old of whether there
was, for example,
any Neanderthal DNA
introduced into Africa?
- Right, so the question
is whether there
is evidence for Neanderthal
DNA in any African population.
We do see traces
of Neanderthal DNA
in some African populations.
We think that most of that is
explained by black migration
from some of these out of Africa
populations back into Africa.
The traces are quite small.
So you could imagine if an
out of African population
carries 2% DNA and
2% of them come back,
that's going to be
maybe 4 parts in 10,000.
So there's a trace amount
that is detectable, mostly
explainable by these kinds
of back migration events.
- This will be the last
question for this--
- Well, well, it'll be a high
point, I hope, for the break.
- There's plenty of time later.
- So I'm [INAUDIBLE],, 59,
recently retired pediatric
neurologist and former redhead.
And I read somewhere
that only 2% or 3%
of the population in
the world is red-headed.
And that they trace it
to the Neanderthal genes.
Is that the BNC2 gene?
And is that something that's on
my genome that could be found?
Or is that a bit of a stretch?
- So the question is, you're
asking about a specific gene
being Neanderthal--
- Apparently, this
is what I read,
that red-headedness is traceable
to the Neanderthal population.
And it's only 2% or 3% of
the world's population.
And I wondered, you mentioned--
I think it was BNC2 gene
was related to hair color.
And I just wondered
if that was the gene
or is there a gene
for red-headedness?
I'll probably leave it at that.
- Yeah, I couldn't catch
the name of the gene.
So maybe we should
take it offline.
[INAUDIBLE]
- Sure, we could
do that offline.
We'll have a break later.
And we can talk offline.
OK, Sriram, that was fantastic.
I didn't even get
to ask a question.
So I'll have to wait.
I have a big question
for you later.
OK.
So with that.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]